das ist unsere forderung schauen sie mal
hier
das ist der impfstoff vom staat den bild
fordert mit den blond gründern natürlich
darauf die uns hier mehr oder weniger
alle gerettet haben 50 euro prämie für
jeden der sich vollständig impfen lässt
statt impfpflicht durch die hintertür
einen bonus vom staat und kein druck auf
familien auszuüben sollen kinder von der
prämie ausgenommen bleiben das geld soll
damit niemand benachteiligt wird auch
rückwirkend ausgezahlt werden können das
ist das was bild die retter fordert
damit kann man jetzt noch nichts
einkaufen also falls du dir denn nachher
noch nehmen willst und uns denn der
kantine bezeichnend nein das wir euch
nicht aber wesentlich für unsere
forderung klaus ja damit ich bin
ich finde ja den unternehmer aus
regensburg wirklich also sensationell
das zu machen und zu sagen das hier ist
mein planquadrat in dem bin ich auch die
regierung und ich tue das zusammen mit
meinen leuten und für meine leute und
für meine kunden damit hier dieser ich
zitiere scheiß endlich mal zu ende ist
das ist grandioses bürgertum das ist
eine vorbildfunktion ich glaube das ist
jetzt schon wenigstens der bayerische
verdienstorden oder das
bundesverdienstkreuz oder der bild
erhält des monats das finde ich so toll
und zwar finde ich in der sache vor ort
toll und als symbol denn natürlich ist
es sowas auch hier beim im profil von
bild durch klingt es muss schluss sein
mit dieser wenn ihr nicht spurt habt ihr
nachteile politik unsere regierung wenn
ihr das nicht macht was wir für richtig
halten dann werdet ihr mal sehen dann
könnt ihr nicht mehr ins restaurant dann
müsst ihr weiter masken tragen dann
müsste er im öffentlichen nahverkehr
keine ahnung weiter riesige abständen
ihr müsst das alles mache ihr kriegt die
straßen warum switched diese regierung
nicht endlich um auf anreize auf bonus
auf loben von von
leuten die es richtig machen wenn man
also an diese quote von 80 prozent
glaubt ich sage das mit einer gewissen
zurückhaltung weil meine sorge ist wenn
sie erreicht ist kommt diese legendäre
regierung oder ihre dann vielleicht noch
legendär nachfolgen und sagt na ja also
80 prozent das ist es jetzt doch nicht
wir haben jetzt neue erkenntnisse müssen
100 prozent sein was ja bekanntermaßen
nicht geht also wenn man aber an dieser
80 prozent glaubt dann muss man doch
alles unternehmen um sie zu kriegen mit
den leuten zusammen und nicht gegen sie
und eine prämie werde das richtige 50
euro journalisten sind meistens
schlechter im rechnen aber aber mal grob
kalkuliert bedeuten wir haben wie viel
wir haben vorgerechnet wir haben
vorgerechnet
[Musik]
2 milliarden wenn ihr mini verrechnet
und dieses geld
diese diese summen will verballern wir
ja in anderen bereichen oder verplanen
sie in anderen bereichen mit großer
hingabe wir haben wir haben mal
durchgerechnet
wir haben mal durchrechnen
lassen und in der karte sieht man wie so
eine impf prämie von 50 euro sind macht
die vergütung für die durchführung der
tests beträgt nämlich zwölf euro und
wenn wir das mal auf vier tests
hochrechnen dann sind wir bei 48 euro
für einmal impfen würde es dann 50 euro
geben weniger aufwand und mehr schutz
außerdem schätzt übrigens das
wirtschaftsinstitut iv den gegenwert
einer impfung für die gesellschaft auf
1500 euro weniger krankheitsfälle die
volkswirtschaft natürlich weniger
belasten 50 euro wären also wirklich
eine lohnende investition
[Musik]